foreign
SEO is Master technique in digital
marketing on page on off-page techniques
are the main reason for SEO success the
future of on-page SEO will prioritize
user experience relevance and structured
data focusing on factors like paid speed
mobile friendliness valuable content and
user intent however off-page SEO will
revolve around the brand reputation user
engagement and contextual link building
with social media impact and local SEO
becoming increasingly significant for
better search engine rankings so if you
are looking to become an SEO
professional then look no further than
simply learns postgraduate program in
digital marketing with this you will
gain all necessary skills in digital
marketing like website creation
behavioral marketing keyword research
search engine optimization Edition
search engine marketing campaign
management social media marketing and
more with knowledge of SEO tools like SC
rankings HootSuite chat GPT Google ads
Google Keyword Planner Google Trends and
there's much more on the list don't miss
out on this incredible opportunity take
action today and enroll in our course to
unlock the digital marketing success
ready to get started click the link in
the description box and embark on your
journey to professional growth and
achievements
before we move ahead consider
subscribing to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply learn without any further Ado
over to our tutors at the end of this
lesson you will be able to describe the
two broad categories of ranking signals
recite best practices for on-page
signals such as title tags header tags
URLs alt text and others identify
on-page SEO practices that you should
avoid and finally describe how natural
language processing aims to understand
the meaning behind the text
on-page optimization as the name
suggests is the practice of optimizing
web pages to rank higher and get
relevant traffic from the search engine
on-page optimization includes both
content and HTML source code
optimization
search engine optimization can be very
complex so when you're trying to
understand it for the first time I find
it very easy just to break it up into
general concepts that you might already
have an understanding of when you look
at the hundreds of signals that go into
SEO they can be broken up into either
relevancy or because sometimes it's both
popularity so relevancy and popularity
out of all these signals they fit into
one of these two things we're going to
break all the signals we have into these
two areas in this section we're going to
talk about the on-page factors that's
because these are the factors that you
have direct impact upon and you can make
a small tweak and have a big impact with
Organic traffic with your on-page
relevancy factors the primary on-page
relevancy factors that I'll cover in
this lesson are title tags and meta
descriptions header tags which are used
for headlines and subheadings website
URLs and URL structure and image alt
text internal links keyword usage and
sitemaps
let's start with one of my favorites and
that is the title tag this is also
called a page title the page title is
not shown on the page now rather it is
displayed on the browser Tab and this is
what makes it highly important is that
in addition to being displayed on the
browser tab it is also the title tag or
the page title that is shown on the text
in the Google search results as the link
to the page
the page title influences both the
click-through rates and people's first
impressions of our website next up we
have the meta description
Now The Meta description can be a bit
confusing
The Meta description is in the code and
it does not influence rankings
but it does influence clicks
people will see your snippet or your
page information in the search engine
results
that gray text is the meta description
if you don't have a meta description
then it may pull information from the
page
you can affect this and improve the
chances of your meta description
appearing if you write a short
descriptive phrase of the content or the
purpose of the page
and just because we edit these elements
does not guarantee that they will show
up
I often say that we affect the change
but we cannot control it
this is because the search engine May
override your changes and show different
content in these areas
sometimes it may help and it might be a
better description but many times it's
not
now let's go to the next element the
header tags these are also referred to
as the heading and subheading
and this is how HTML was built when the
web was first created
it enables a logical hierarchy of
content
so starting with the headline then
displaying a subheading and then
subheadings after that
the idea here is that you're
establishing a hierarchy of information
so you start with the H1 like a
newspaper there's only one main headline
per page
it describes the main purpose of the
page
then a subheading the H2 this is how you
break the sub content into sub
categories obviously you'll want to use
a keyword in there as well
you see by describing the purpose of the
page in the headline and then again in a
subheading you're naturally going to use
your primary and secondary keywords
because you're going to associate them
with the product or the purpose and the
benefit
the key is to keep it short
you see after the headline are the
subcategories the H2S and then your H3
is typically used as a paragraph heading
now putting the keyword in these
headings alone does not make your page
optimized
remember the purpose is to provide a
quick reference for people to find the
content they need within seconds
so short explanatory heading and
subheadings paragraph headings are very
effective
and naturally you'll be using keywords
to help people locate the information
that is most important to them
now if we go back to the search engine
results page the serp there is another
element in that listing the page title
is the large Blue text The Meta
description is the gray text now the
green text is the URL of the page that
is listed this is the address of the
page just like the address for your home
the internet knows that the URL is the
address for that page this is extremely
important for SEO for a variety of
reasons the most important though is
your keyword usage I like to make sure
that I have at least one Relevant Word
in the URL now also here keep it short
one of the worst things you can do is
have a URL full of keywords or even
worse hyphenate them all remember people
use these urls
they provide context for the page people
also copy and paste URLs into Mobile
messages emails and Social Links so it
is extremely important to keep these
short succinct and I like to say
readable
now I've just briefly touched about the
importance of the URL and now let's look
at the URL structure
first let's start with the primary core
of the URL the domain name
in the example with the URL I have here
example.com that's the domain name so
this is the first thing that people see
with your online business
now be on the internet this is going to
be what's in all of your ads emails
brochures business cards and online your
social profiles all of your marketing
efforts are going to drive people to
this domain there's a lot of advice
about buying or using domains that have
your keywords in them and unfortunately
domains have been being sold for decades
so there's less chance of finding a
domain with the keywords you want now
the search engines don't make the
keyword used in the domain a primary
ranking signal so that's good however
the domain is your business it needs to
be memorable if you have a very I call
it a spammy looking domain name with
multiple words and hyphens or one that's
hard to spell or confusing people are
going to make an initial impression off
of that so make sure you have something
that's going to make a great first
impression here's the rule for a domain
name something that's easy to spell and
easy to pronounce ideally sure it's
something you can type and share some
thing you're going to be able to put on
a business card and be proud of not
something that you bought primarily
because you want it for SEO reasons and
you think with that you're going to
succeed as an example just think about
Amazon their domain name says nothing
about books and yet it grew to be one of
the largest e-commerce companies in the
world the same with Alibaba or Google
their domain names were not the keyword
but their marketing and branding built
their company now everything after the
domain is a subdirectory this is based
on your website organization as an
example if you have a website selling
shoes then the subdirectory can be
called shoes it's easy right the
subdirectory is the folder that contains
the relevant files or Pages for that
group think of a file folder with
documents inside the file folder is
usually based on a major category of
content or products now inside the
folder are individual documents or Pages
these files or Pages usually come after
the subdirectory in this example you see
the file.html the next step in
optimizing the URL is to name the page
in a way that explains the content of
the page to use our eCommerce shoe
website a page name would usually be a
specific product name this way you would
end up with domain name forward slash
shoes as the category forward slash
brand name running shoe insert that here
if you've ever looked at the HTML that
make up the instructions of the page
you'll understand a bit more of how
search engines get the information from
the page the text on the page and the
markup such as the headings provide
instructions as to where the text is
located the importance and prominence of
the text in addition to the arrangement
of the overall page HTML is a set of
instructions for a browser to assemble
the page and the search engines use that
as well now the search engines spiders
cannot see images as the internet
developed many attributes were added to
provide for accessibility and additional
features users that are site impaired
cannot see images
and the alternative text tag describes
the image
further there are many times when our
bandwidth isn't strong and not all of
the images will load in that case we
need the alt text description to provide
the context of the image and its purpose
search engines use this alt text
description to gain additional context
about the page the content of the image
and its purpose now we have an entire
section on links but at this point I
just want to cover internal links an
internal link is a link from one page on
your website to another page of your own
website now this is important from a
relevancy perspective you'll see
internal links in your main navigation
you'll likely have a link that says home
one that says contact us or about our
company
what you're showing to search engines
and to humans is that this section if
you click on this link is about our
company or this is where you find our
contact information
you see these links are not votes like
external links
however they provide relevance and
context to the information on your own
website
let's dive in a little more on keywords
when a search engine crawls and
processes your website it doesn't simply
look for the instances of specific
keywords
it's a lot more complex than that
it's using a technology called natural
language processing
natural language processing uses
algorithms to try to understand the
meaning of text
you see search engine processing is
attempting to be human
this is the same way that people see and
hear the words and we're using the words
to find the meaning expressed in the
words
similarly when a search engine goes to
your website it may see keywords but
it's looking for the context of those
words
you may say football but just having the
word football repeated throughout your
website isn't going to help you rank
specifically for football
what you need to do and what is more
common in actual human conversation
happens very naturally
when we talk about football we use
naturally additional words such as goal
and referee and World Cup you see Google
and the other search engines are going
to take these into account by usage of
other synonyms and other common words
you present the context of a bigger
broader idea for your website
the next site signal that we have is
site Maps now there are two kinds of
site Maps there's the site map that is
for humans and there is the site map
that are for search engine robots
crawlers or spiders
the one that is for human is called an
HTML sitemap you've probably seen these
before the link is generally in the
footer of a website if you click on it
it shows you the major sections of the
website provide some search
functionality but looking at it as a
human it shows you the hierarchy of the
website and where to find important
information
it shows how everything fits together
now there's something else that exists
called an XML sitemap
it's not linked from any page of your
website but exists as an independent
file on your server
now this is something you can see but it
is formatted for search engine spiders
using a programming language called XML
it shows the hierarchy and the priority
of each of the URLs of the website every
page every document every image and it
also shows the date that each page was
last updated or changed
so at this point we've covered a lot of
things that are important and things
that you should be doing when optimizing
your on-page content
now let's go a different direction and
cover things that you should not be
doing keyword stuffing hidden text
repetitive anchor text and cloaking the
first one is keyword stuffing now back
in the early days of search engine
optimization people used to increase the
instances of words on the page now this
is well before natural language
processing at that time search engines
were looking for occurrences of specific
words well search engines they're very
smart about this what may have worked 20
years ago or 10 years ago keyword
stuffing does not work
you're not going to rank better for any
given phrase by including it a dozen or
more times on the page in fact you might
get an over optimization penalty by
constantly repeating the same word over
and over focus on writing content that
engages with your visitors and uses
language naturally now the next one is
hidden text unfortunately I still see
this this is when you write content that
is solely for search engines and not for
people now typically it is attempted by
writing a lot of repetitive keywords as
text coloring it white and placing it
against a white background
see this was developed as another way to
add more keyword stuff text without the
user seeing the overuse of keywords now
it didn't work too well in the past and
it definitely does not work today this
tactic backfires in two ways first
search engines can tell when it's white
text on a white background it's easy to
tell from a computer science point of
view
search engines read the HTML and in the
HTML are the instructions for colors
when you hide text modern search engines
are smart enough to figure it out
probably better than a human now
secondly it's done to hide repetitive
keyword stuff text which is the second
thing against you these outdated
unprofessional tactics will most likely
get a website penalized by the search
engines the next one is repetitive
anchor text
you may have followed a link to a page
when looking for a business or
information and instead of the
information you want you get a page that
doesn't feel like it was written for
people
every sentence is redundant repetitive
and almost every keyword is linked even
when there doesn't need to be a link
it confuses the flow of the information
on the page now again this used to be a
tactic that sometimes would work but
it's no longer helpful
search engines and their natural
language processing algorithms have
advanced significantly they can tell
when something's not readable when
something is probably intended for
machines and rankings but not for people
search engines will figure it out please
don't waste time on redundant links
trying to inflate the relevance of your
links and Pages the last thing to cover
here is cloaking cloaking is the idea of
showing one thing to the search engines
and something entirely different to
humans now this is related to the rest
of the tactics I just covered it's
something that used to work but it was
expressly against the search engine
guidelines while it may have worked if
the search engine is discovered it on
your website you could have been
penalized or dropped from the search
engine results entirely now we've
covered all of the most important
on-page optimization factors let's take
a look at what the theoretically
perfectly optimized page would look like
in this example we can see many of these
elements being used together you can
also see that the base key phrase
digital camera is being repeated but
always included with a specific contact
next first at the top of the page is the
URL which has digital cameras in the
address the page title follows using the
context of the information and adding
the word reviews you can also see at the
top of the page that the main navigation
and secondary navigation also called the
breadcrumb navigation provides context
of the Page's location within the entire
website and natural keyword usage
the H1 headline is the key phrase but
also happens to simply be the best title
for the content of the page
the subsequent subheadings provide
additional information such as ratings
recommendations and features
the links provide relevant ways to
access additional content
the image utilizes alt text there are
also clear calls to action which provide
relevant offers to visitors
as you can see the context of all of the
content is very strong and sends a clear
relevancy signal to both search engines
and readers
to conclude this section I'd like to
cover the top influencing factors now
sometimes you may find these as lists
but I found it a bit more practical to
separate them into categories
typically every year you'll find these
collections of lists from surveys
experts or speculation
some are from testing but honestly you
can't ever truly test a search engine as
they change a little bit with every
algorithm
so the best thing is to take from these
lists these factors that are the tried
and true factors over the years that
have worked consistently
also those tactics that not only make
your website more effective with users
they tend to do well with search engines
so if a tactic serves that Dual Purpose
it's a good tactic
so these are not exclusive and have to
lists for every situation but guides and
indicators for you to use the top
on-page factors from surveys opinions
and data are these
a relevant page title page headings
anchor text links a keyword-based URL
a keyword or contextual file name such
as page name image name or PDF file name
alt text and images and finally what you
do with the content on a page to make it
more readable lists bullet points and
bolded text
the top factors for off-page linking
tend to contain these items
the total number of domains linking to
you
the number of Highly influential domains
linking to you
the number of unique domain IP addresses
the total backlinks without no follow
limits
the total relevant anchor text in links
to you
and finally the types and context of
keywords in Anchor text links
the domain also contributes factors to
your overall rankings such as the age of
the domain which would include ownership
information such as the length of time
owned and operated by a company
the real business information tied to
that domain such as the business address
being the same as the business
registration address for the domain
in addition the signals from social
accounts driving visits to the domain
functionally the search engines also
utilize some attribution based on the
quality of programming of the website
for instance taking care of the basic
search engine Protocols of the
robots.txt file XML sitemap and https
protocol
websites that Implement these features
have shown that they are familiar with
search engine guidelines and protocol
now one of the changes over the past few
years has been the implementation of
page speed as an increasing ranking
Factor
slow loading pages with a lot of
extraneous code that slowed the delivery
of the page will be penalized as they
take away from the user experience
optimizing the page code speeding up the
load time of the page can directly
impact your rankings and this is closely
related to the mobile friendliness of
your website
if your website is not mobile friendly
it will be limited in visibility as
Google's primary index is focused on
mobile devices and mobile delivery
behavioral factors are the newest
factors and with the Advent of
artificial intelligence it is making
determining the intent and the is making
determinings easier
for a search engine to derive a judgment
of relevancy based on interaction
while the extent of these signals is not
fully known it is suspected that they
are minor but growing in importance
these include the amount of users that
search for a brand name business's name
and go to that result showing brand
awareness
also the amount of direct visits
bypassing search
time on page pages per session which is
also called the depth of visit
and lastly the behavior of a Searcher
from the results page how many results
are clicked how many times do they
return to the results this evaluation is
looking to judge if the results
presented were satisfactory or deficient
for that query so if you are looking to
become an SEO professional then look no
further than simply learns postgraduate
program in digital marketing click the
link in the description box and embark
on your journey to professional growth
and achievements here is a question for
you what is the purpose of SEO Option 1
to drive organic traffic option 2
improving online visibility option 3
improve search engine rankings option
for all of the above let us know your
answers in the comment section below and
get a heart from Simply learn also don't
forget to subscribe simply learn and hit
the Bell icon to never miss any updates
from Simply learn let's not
procrastinate any longer and see what we
have for you in this video
we will Begin by understanding what are
the different types of SEO followed by
what is off-page SEO the difference
between on page and off-page SEO
importance of of page SEO we will put a
light on link and non-link related of
page SEO factors followed by top 5 of
page optimization techniques also by the
end of this video you will know top 10
best off-page optimization tools and see
the jobs and salaries of this stream so
let's begin with the types of SEO there
are three types of SEO namely on page
SEO of page SEO and Technical SEO so
let's start with on-page seo on-page seo
refers to the optimizing individual
Pages or web pages to improve their
search engine rankings and drive more
traffic to a website this includes
optimizing elements such as title tags
meta descriptions heading content
interlinking and website structure the
next we have is off-page SEO of speech
SEO refers to optimizing a website's
external factors that affects its search
engine rankings such as link building
social media and brand mentions the goal
of off-page SEO is to increase the
authority and relevance of the website
thereby improving its search engine
ranking the next we have is technical
SEO refers to optimizing a website's
technical aspects to improve search
engine ranking this includes optimizing
elements such as website speed mobile
responsiveness site architecture and
structured data technical SEO is
critical for ensuring that search
engines can crawl and index your website
effectively we have already covered some
on-page optimization practices in our
earlier videos in this video we will be
focusing majorly on the off-page
optimization techniques or off-page SEO
so let's understand what is off-page SEO
of page SEO refers to the optimization
of external factors that can affect a
website's search engine ranking but not
directly related to content or structure
of website itself this includes building
high quality backlinks to the website
from the reputable ones engaging your
audience on social media platforms
building your own Brands online
reputation through mentions and reviews
of page SEO is essential for
establishing a website's Authority and
relevance in search engine rankings
search engines use backlinks and other
off-beat signals to determine the
credibility and popularity of website
which in turn can impact its search
engine rankings a strong off-page SEO
strategy can help a website to attract
more organic traffic traffic improve in
search engine ranking and ultimately
increase its visibility and online
repetition now let's understand the
difference between on-page and off-page
SEO the main difference between on-page
and off-page SEO is that on page SEO
involves optimizing the elements on the
website's individual Pages while of page
SEO focuses on optimizing external
factors that can impact a website's
search engine ranking optimizing
elements on website in on-page SEO
includes optimization of title tags meta
descriptions headings content images and
interlinking this improves the relevance
and understandability of websites pages
for search engine however the external
factor in off-page SEO includes link
building social media engagement and
online repetition management so let's
see why off-page SEO is important
off-page SEO is important for improving
the search engine ranking of a website
by establishing its Authority and
relevance search engines use external
factors such as backlinks social media
engagement
influencer Outreach and online
repetition management to determine the
credibility and popularity of a website
getting backlinks from another reputable
websites are critical factor in off-page
SEO as the signals to search engines
that the content on the linked website
is valuable and relevant brand awareness
can be increased with the help of social
media engagement influencer Outreach and
online repetition management so with a
glimpse of its importance let's move
ahead link and non-link related off-page
SEO factors link related factors has a
complete control over the links of the
off-page optimization here are few link
related factors that can affect your
website number and quality of external
links pointing to a website anchor text
used in the external link relevancy of
external link to the content of the
linked website freshness of the external
links diversity of the external links
from different domains Authority and
trustworthiness of the domains linking
to the website non-link related factors
have control over everything else other
than the link a few non-link related
off-page factors includes social media
engagement and activity online
repetition management including reviews
and ratings on directories and review
websites brand mentions and citations on
other websites even if not linked
influencer Outreach and partnership
local SEO strategies such as optimizing
Google my business listings and local
directories content marketing efforts
including guest blogging and sharing
content on social media platforms
anyways we are going to cover many of
them in the upcoming part of the video
now that we have gained enough
understanding of what is off-page SEO
let's discuss top 5 off-page
optimization tips so starting with the
tip number one link building
one of the most important of beach SEO
techniques is link building which
involves acquiring high quality
backlinks from the authoritative and
relevant websites this can done through
guest blogging broken link building
influencer Outreach and other link
building techniques the next tip we have
is social media engagement social media
platforms provide a valuable opportunity
to engage with target audience and build
brand awareness
by creating and sharing high quality
content on the social media platform
businesses can increase their online
visibility and improve their search
engine ranking towards the next tip
which is online repetition management
online repetition management involves
monitoring and managing a business's
online repetition by responding to
reviews engaging with customers and
monitoring mentions of the business
online by maintaining a positive online
repetition businesses can improve their
search engine rankings and attract more
customers moving towards the next tip
which is local SEO optimization
local SEO techniques such as optimizing
Google my business listings building
local citations and participating in
local directories can help businesses to
rank higher in local search results next
and the last tip that we have is content
marketing
content marketing involves creating and
sharing valuable content and relevant
content such as blog posts infographics
and videos by creating high quality
content businesses can attract backlinks
social shares and other forms of
Engagement that can improve the search
engine rankings over time now that we
have understood how off-page
optimization can be done effectively
with these five tips let's now move
ahead with this video to know some
helpful tools for off-page SEO so here
is the list of some helpful tools you
may require during off-page SEO
practices so let's see all the tools in
short one by one let's start by knowing
most most is an all-in-one SEO tool that
can help businesses with keyword
research link building online repetition
management and much more it provides a
range of features for tracking rankings
analyzing backlinks and improving
website performance the next tool we
have is majestic Majestic is a link
building tool that provides
comprehensive backlink data and other
SEO metrics it can be used to identify
New Link building opportunities and
monitor competitor backlinks next we
have is ahrefs ahrefs is a powerful SEO
tool that can help with link building
and competitor analysis it provides
comprehensive backlink data and other
SEO metrics that can be used to identify
New Link building opportunities next
tool we have in the list is semrush or
formally known as sem Rush semrush is an
all-in-one SEO tool that can help with
keyword research backlink analysis and
social media engagement it provides
valuable insights into websites of page
SEO performance and can help businesses
to optimize their online presence the
next we have is ninja Outreach ninja
Outreach is a tool that can help
businesses with influencer Outreach and
Link building it provides a range of
features for finding influencer in any
Niche managing Outreach campaigns and
tracking results next tool in the list
is pitch box pitch box is a link
building an influencer Outreach tool
that can help businesses with
personalized Outreach campaigns it
provides a range of features for finding
link building opportunities managing
relationships with website owners and
tracking performance to the next tool
which is Buzz stream bus stream is a
link building tool that can help
businesses streamline their Outreach
efforts and manage their relationships
with influence pencil and other website
owners
provides a range of features for
managing link building campaigns
tracking progress and monitoring
performance the next tool we have is
Google Alerts Google Alerts is a free
tool that can be used to monitor
mentions of a business or brand online
by setting up alerts for Relevant
keywords businesses can stay on the top
of their online repetition and address
any negative comments or reviews in the
timely manner next tool we have is
hootsu HootSuite is a social media
management tool that can help businesses
to manage and schedule their social
media content across multiple platforms
it provides valuable insight into the
social media engagement and can help
businesses to improve their overall
social media strategy and coming to the
last tool in the list is mention mention
is an online repetition management tool
that can help businesses to monitor
their online mentions across social
media news sites and other platforms it
provides real-time alerts and advanced
analytics to help businesses manage
their online repetition so these are
just a few examples of many off-page SEO
tools available depending on your
specific needs and goals there may be
other tools that are better and suited
to your business now that you know the
roadmap to become a successful Optimizer
these are just a few examples of many
off-page SEO tools available depending
on your specific needs and goals there
may be other tools that are better
suited for your business now that you
know the roadmap to become a successful
Optimizer let's have a look at the jobs
and salaries for off-page optimization
rules off-page SEO jobs can vary
depending on the company industry and
location some common job titles in this
Fields include link building specialist
SEO Outreach coordinator digital
marketing specialist and content
marketing manager salaries of off-page
SEO jobs are widely depending on the
factors such as experience job title
location and the company size in general
the entry level positions may start
around 1.35 000 to Dollar forty five
thousand per year while more senior
roles such as SEO manager or director of
digital marketing can earn up to dollar
one lakh per year as in U.S however in
India the salaries of off-page SEO jobs
may vary the entry level positions in
off-page seum start around 2.5 to 4
lakhs per year in Indian currency INR
while more senior roles such as SEO
manager and director of digital
marketing can earn up to 10 lakhs INR
per year or even more so concludingly
off-page SEO is an essential component
of any successful digital marketing
strategy by building a strong online
repetition and acquiring high quality
backlinks from authoritative websites
business can improve their search engine
rankings drive more organic traffic to
their website and ultimately increase
their revenue with the help of effective
off-page SEO techniques and tools
business can stay ahead of the
competition and achieve a long-term
success in the Online Marketplace with
the help of effective off-page SEO
techniques and tools businesses can stay
ahead of the competition and Achieve
long-term success in the Online
Marketplace so if you are looking to
become an SEO professional then look no
further than simply learns postgraduate
program in digital marketing thing click
the link in the description box and
embark on your journey to professional
growth and achievements let's go to
google.com
how to make pizza
so here you can see there are number of
results
these type of results are called red
Snippets and Below you'll get the list
of top 10 search results
on the first page of the Subs
so here we are we are going to find the
backlinks for the first and the last
result
so let's copy the link
open it in a new tab
and
copy the link and now we'll go to rf's
backlink Checker
just to add to your information rf's
backlink Checker is a free backing
Checker tool
now here we will be adding the URL
and check backlinks
so here you can see there are 288
backlinks with the 22 percent of do
follow links we are going to learn the
do follow and no follow links in the
coming part of the video so stay tuned
now let's check the backlinks for the
last search result
which is
kill
we'll open the link and
copy the link here
go to rf's Checker
and add the URL and again the same
procedure
so okay so here we can find that number
of backlinks are more as compared to
previous one here there are 346
backlinks with six percent of do follow
links so now there is a question that
though there are there is uh more
backlinks in the last result why it's
not why it's ranking to the last
position so here is the answer that
having more number of backlink is
definitely a ranking Factor but the
backlink should be do follow links
if you have more number of do follow
links then it is more likely to result
high on the search results as compared
to
less number of do follow links that's
why the last that's why here you can see
that this link is at the last of the
search result
whereas this one is at the first Okay so
now again
let's search for best
jogging
shoes
okay we are not taking the ads we will
check for the organic results which I
hear
so let's click on the first result
copy the link
and go to rf's backlink Checker
add your url and check for backlinks
meanwhile we'll go and check for the
last result
okay this this one is the last
copy the link
go to rf's backlink Checker
and enter the URL
check back links
okay
so here you can see a huge difference
the first first result is having
3395 with 94 of do follow links
but as the last result is having only
183 backlinks with only two percent of
do follow links definitely to rank
higher there are several factors and
backlinks are one of them let's
understand what backlinks are when a web
page receives a hyperlink from another
website it is known as a backlink a
backlink is also known as inbound links
let's understand this more clearly
this is an article on best pizza company
it has a list of pizzas mentioned
here you can see a link attached to each
company
when you click on the link it opens the
website or the company's home page here
the company's home page gets one
backlink from the website on which
article is present
now as we are familiar with what
backlinks are let's understand what make
backlinks an important ranking Factor
when a web page receives more and more
backlinks this helps search engine
understand that your web pages content
is valuable which makes other websites
to link to You thereby gaining their
trust
as search engines loves the unique and
valuable content they consider it to
rank high in the search results
this makes backlinks an important factor
and a symbol of trust as well
however it is not necessary that if you
get lots of backlinks that means you
will rank high for sure
you will rank high only when you get
high quality backlinks
backlinks are said to be high quality
when link juice or authority from one
website is passed to another
and to understand this there is a need
for proper understanding of no follow
and do follow links a website can link
to your page either by do follow
or by no follow links do follow links
are beneficial in terms of SEO when a
website links back to your site by do
follow link it passes The Authority or
the link juice
of their website to yours
this helps to improve the authority of
your website thereby positively
affecting the ranking
coming to no follow links these links do
not pass Authority or link juice to your
website therefore these are not
beneficial in terms of SEO however even
though it directly does not affect the
ranking of your website still no follow
links are good for driving user traffic
from one website to another
now that we have gained knowledge about
do follow and no follow links I would
like to bring your attention to some of
the practices followed by optimizers to
get the backlinks
white hat and black hat techniques to
get backlinks optimizers mostly follow
white hat or black hat techniques
the white hat technique helps to gain
backlinks under search engine guidelines
talking about blackhead techniques this
involves spammy methods of gaining
backlinks and one can get penalized by
search engines if search engines detect
the black hat methods so on a serious
note we recommend you to follow white
hat techniques strictly
so without taking a minute let's start
understanding the methods of how to
build backlinks
here we go with our first technique
which is skyscraper technique
this technique is originally said to be
found by Brian Dean the founder of
backlinko publishing a skyscraper
content can help you to bring backlink
from high Authority sites for this you
need to do the basic research and find
the content that is doing well in your
industry
once you find the content create a
better version of this content with
additional unique information
now all you need is to promote your
content
then you can reach out to experts with
similar interest and ask them to add the
URL of your content which will be an
add-on to their existing content
and that's it
another method of building backlinks is
publishing detail guides
detail guides are the form of longer
content studies say that longer contents
tends to gain more backlinks
however remember that publishing longer
content will work only if the content is
unique and informative getting to know
about broken link building
all you need to do is find the
informative Pages which are relevant to
your industry on the web that have
deadlinks or 404 pages
four not four pages have a negative
impact on search engines
if you have relevant content that could
replace this 4 not per page
do reach out to the owner of the content
and have a humble ask
to replace the dead link with your
content definitely it's difficult but
yes this technique really works
next we can get backlinks by finding
listicles
to add plus to your knowledge listicles
are a piece of writings that has list
included in them
all you need to do is find the content
which has list of relevant topics now
check if it includes your site also
if not you can ask the owner of the
content to include your site with a
brief description of how it is helpful
and relevant to the existing content now
let's talk about another technique
helpful in gaining backlinks which is
guest blogging guest blogging is a
simple and easy way to earn backlinks
first you need to identify blogging site
with high domain Authority create a blog
post relevant to your industry
with the links of your site and add this
post to the blogging site
do not add too many links as they will
appear spammy in the eyes of search
engines which may prove harmful to your
site
next we move towards
another technique which is link Gap
building
Gap analysis is the quickest way from
which one can easily discover the link
building opportunities by carrying out
link Gap analysis you can find the sites
that link to your competitors but not
you
so suppose if you find a website that
links to more than one of your
competitors their chances of linking to
you increases as we have seen some of
the effective backlink building methods
now let's see some tools you will need
for building backlinks using the above
methods here we go with our first tool
helpful in backlink building which is
sem rush it is helpful and competitor
analysis and finding link gaps it has
free as well as paid version
next we have RFS
link intersect feature helps to get the
reports on the sites that link to your
competitors but not you
this feature comes under the paid
version
upcoming tool is another interesting
tool which is helpful in building
backlinks which is group High
it helps you to get bloggers reach
this tool is a paid tool
next we have Hunter dot IO
it is an email address finder that helps
you to get email addresses of people
from a particular domain or even their
personal IDs it has free as well as paid
versions
we have learned almost all the aspects
of backlink building now let's have a
quick look at what is in the future of
backlinks backlinks are one of the most
important factors in search engine
ranking as it shows the trust of one
site into another
gaining high quality backlink makes the
search engines understand that the
content on your website is valuable
thereby making it eligible for higher
rankings however due to spammy methods
backlinks are the factor that can be
easily manipulated
as we know that search engine algorithms
are continuously updated backlinks will
continue to be an important ranking
Factor but the unique content and
user-centric content will be more valued
here we wrap up on page and off-page SEO
tutorial listen to what our Learners say
about our courses in their own words
change is inevitable but growth is
optional
for me both came hand in hand
I successfully changed my career from
software development to digital
marketing and simply learn present at
the perfect route hi I'm rimajraf from
Dubai and I have completed the pgp in
digital marketing from Simply learn with
Purdue University when I shifted to
Dubai from Sri Lanka in 2015 I joined a
group of company as a software engineer
but my interest in content creation
attracted me towards the marketing
industry intrigued by the marketing
functions I decided to take up a
challenge that would change my life
forever I aim for a career change as
risky as it was the rewards were truly
overwhelming even though the journey
wasn't easy the pgp in digital marketing
with photo University acted as not only
a catalyst but a game changer for my
career change with no profiling
certification in marketing domain it was
difficult for me to transition and
change my career towards completely
so I decided to upskill with the
professional certification program
I just simply learn because of its
tremendously High waiting to be rated as
one of the best Education portal online
worldwide is surely promising not only
were the ratings I but also the courses
were economically charged the modules
were very informative and amazing I
still refer to those while in the final
stage of my course I told my Superior
about the certification program I was
doing and then it offered me a digital
marketing role in the marketing
department as a digital marketing
executive yes that's how smooth it was
after working for a few years in the
same company as a digital marketing
executive I switched to a new role as a
digital marketing manager with this my
skill upgraded my salary increase and my
self-confidence boost alongside numerous
other positive outcomes I had a chance
to take a challenge and change my career
domain all together
and I took it So currently I am pursuing
masters of Masters program from Simply
learn where I would complete eight
Masters program including artificial
intelligence cloud computing and devops
and many more growing requires moving
out of our comfort zones if you like
this video share it with your friends
add your queries in the comment section
and our expert will be happy to answer
them thanks for watching this video
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here